Joris.
You have taught us much. I
mean, when you think about it,
we now know a lot more
about the Black Death
and we know pretty much
Do we?
all there is to know
about the Netherlands.
And Belgium, yeah.
Yeah and Belgium as well.
But I do have to ask you,
you're wearing a Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles t-shirt.
That leads me to believe you're a fan?
Yes, quite a big fan.
I also have some Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle tattoos.
Oh, I can't really see those. Show them.
Show them close up.
Oh my God shredder.
OH!
Great.
Wait, that's insane.
Yeah.
That is quite detailed.
Stunning.
Look at that.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Tell us about shre-
Oh my God.
Okay, which one is that?
Which one?
Whoa, I can tell you.
Is that Leonardo?
I can tell you. That's Michelangelo.
Thanks. Yeah thanks, Matt.
That's absolutely right.
So Matt, do you really know,
you know a lot about this?
I was into them when they first came out
and there were these
underground, black and white,
violent comic books when
I was in junior high
but I don't know the
modern version of them.
Oh yeah, I'm that way about The Muppets.
I like the old underground
black and white Muppets.
They were bloody.
I'm telling you.
Joris, really?
You can back me up?
I like The Muppets.
The old Muppets I'm talking about.
It was really subversive and
they were all doing drugs
and our crumb created them.
Yeah, it was really only cool people
knew about The Muppets then.
Yeah, there was borderline
Yeah.
skin flicks too where there was
a lot of Muppet nude
Yep, it's a very
hipster thing.
Yeah.
Very hipster thing to say, of course,
that you knew them before they were cool.
Yeah.
Exactly. Exactly, my point.
Don't, don't.
Yeah.
Conventionally attractive and cool guy.
No, no. I think
the attack now is on Gourley.
Oh yeah.
For trying to-
I appreciate
that deflection though.
Trying to pretend
that he only knows that the old cool
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
and didn't go with the crowd,
the mob, if you will.
It's true.
I still have those comics
signed by the artists,
Eastman and Laird.
Oh wow.
Yeah.
It's incredible. Well,
you just talked yourself
out of that hole.
I now totally respect you and
think you're the grooviest.
(co-hosts laughing)
Who are we of the Ninja Turtles,
Joris?
Yeah.
That's a good question.
I mean, the obvious one
is Donatello, right.
That would be you, Matt.
What-
Because you do the machines.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's the one-
You're the engineer.
In an action movie, he's the guy in a van,
with the headset,
who's um...
And the glasses.
Really yeah, burning no calories at all
and clicking and figuring
out and then I would be...
Who's the really cool,
conventionally attractive,
Jazz, cigarette smoking Ninja Turtle?
I guess the coolest one,
and also the brawler
of the four,
Yeah, that's right.
it's Raphael.
Oh no.
Yeah, that's me.
Raphael.
That's not you.
That's Sona.
Yeah.
And that would be Sona?
Yeah, that would-
Yeah, definitely.
That's not you.
Well, looks like
That's Sona.
it's gone to Sona. All right so,
Raphael is the coolest one.
who's left?
Is there a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
that can't go out in the sun?
I'm trying to,
I want my own turtle.
So I have two answers, right.
One is the one you want
because Leonardo is
the leader of the pack.
Yeah.
Oh.
Undoubtedly.
Yeah.
But Michelangelo is the orange one.
Oh.
Who likes pizza? Isn't that Michelangelo?
I just wanna state for
the record that I was into
the Ninja Turtles before
their bandanas changed colors.
I just (indistinct).
Okay, we get it.
I just want that
on the record.
Yeah, very cool.
It was cool.
Like the black and white
ones you signed.
A lot of sex.
Wow.
Incredible. I was really-
You're Leonardo,
that's cool.
Yeah. I'm Leonardo. I think
let's just leave it at that,
not the orange one.
Let's leave it at that.
I don't wanna be the orange one.
because that's demeaning.
So you're Michelangelo
'cause you have the tattoo.
Yeah.
Well, yeah. I have 'em on my body
so I want to take Michelangelo,
if that's fine for you guys.
It's fine, it's fine.
What do you mean?
It's fine.
I have a little screen here
that shows me when
we've lost the listener.
Oh God. We hit this Teenage
Mutant thing and just
Does it model the population
from the Black Death?
Yeah, it looks exactly like that.
It looks exactly like that.
It gets right up to the middle which is
we were killing it with our,
Jean-Claude Van Damme
Belgium and then you hit
Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles and we lost 80%.
Were we killing it though?
Yeah.
All right, everybody.
Chicken butt holes to bubos, let's go.
But save those bubos.
Save those bubos, that's good eating.
Bubo was the name of the owl
in the "Clash of the Titans".
Yes. Is there a punishment
room we can build
in this podcast studio?
Isn't there a place where we could,
where every now and then
Gourley has to go in
and we shut it and you
just have to be in there
for like I bet like a
naughty boy for 10 minutes.
Isolation booth
on quiz shows
Yeah.
when the (indistinct)
(Conan laughing)